it's not always about what you eat it's
what you eat together
[Music]
eating certain foods together can help
you absorb more nutrients here's some
examples spinach and strawberries
your stomach's pH makes it hard to
absorb the iron in plants vitamin C can
help with this its acidity converts the
iron into a more absorbable form adding
100 milligrams of vitamin C can boost
iron absorption by 4 times another good
combo for this trick is black beans and
red peppers raw vegetables plus eggs
many raw vegetables contain
disease-fighting carotenoids but
carotenoids are hard to absorb the fat
from egg yolks can help by eating three
cooked eggs with your vegetables you can
absorb over three times as many
carotenoids turmeric plus black pepper
turmeric contains a pigment called
curcumin studies show curcumin can help
prevent and treat neurodegenerative
cardiovascular pulmonary metabolic
autoimmune and malignant diseases but
the human gut has a hard time absorbing
curcumin Pipper in a major component in
black pepper can help one study found
that adding 20 milligrams of Pipper in
to two grams of curcumin boosted its
availability by 2,000 % caution too much
curcumin can increase risk of kidney
stones
salad plus oil-based dressings add some
healthy fat to your salad an easy way to
do it is with a drizzle of oil-based
dressing the oils fat helps you absorb
more carotenoids from the salad meat and
rosemary cooking meat at high
temperatures forms heterocyclic amines
animal studies reveal heterocyclic
amines are linked to certain cancers a
definitive link in humans is unclear
however rosemary has antioxidants that
help prevent heterocyclic amines adding
rosemary before cooking reduces these by
50 to 90 percent sweet potatoes and
spinach sweet potatoes are rich with
vitamin A but your body needs zinc to
transport vitamin A in the blood
studies show people low in zinc
don't release as much vitamin A from the
liver so eat foods high in zinc like
spinach with your sweet potatoes so the
next time you make dinner make sure
you're getting the most out of it
[Music]
you